one of Joe Biden's very last acts before
leaving office aside from all those
presidential pardons was to release in
December what the White House called the
first ever US national strategy to
counter
islamophobia this document asserts that
islamophobia in America is a byproduct
of hate for and racism against Muslims
thus the first of the document's four
strategies to counter islamophobia is to
increase awareness of hatred against
Muslims and Arabs and broaden
recognition of these community's
heritages Muslims and Arab Americans
have helped build our country since its
founding but they have also routinely
experienced hate discrimination and bias
due to baseless stereotypes
fearmongering and
Prejudice let's for now ignore the
demonstrably false claim that Muslims
have helped build our country since its
founding in reality Muslims were the
first to terrorize our country since its
founding as I will presently show and
let's instead focus on the assertion
that Muslims have routinely experienced
hate discrimination and bias due to
baseless
stereotypes there are only two ways to
understand this either Americans are
really dumb Andor evil buying into and
acting on any meaningless stereotype
thrown their way or else what Muslims
routinely experience is not built a top
baseless stereotypes but rather
something else perhaps reality history
argues for this second interpretation
Muslims have indeed routinely
experienced aversion from non-muslims
but that's because non-muslims have
always understood often from direct and
personal experience what Islam is all
about the fact is from the very start
Western peoples especially their
luminaries portrayed Islam as a hostile
and violent Force often in terms that
would make today's islamophobe blush
they did so for the simple reason that
for centuries they were on the receiving
end of Islamic violence and conquests
but it wasn't just what they personally
experienced at the hands of Muslims that
developed this ancient phobia to Islam
as already discussed in a previous video
as far back as the 7th Century Islam's
scriptures became available to nearby
Christians such as John of Damascus born
around 675 one of History's earliest
islamophobes based solely on these
primary sources of Islam Christians
concluded that Muhammad was a
demon-possessed false prophet who had
very obviously concocted a Creed to
justify the
worst to justify the worst depravities
of man for Dominion plunder cruelty and
carnality this view prevailed for well
over a millennium throughout Europe and
it was augmented by the fact that
Muslims were still well over a
millennium after Muhammad invading
Christian territories plundering them
and abducting their women and children
as mentioned the United States first
conflict with Islam indeed its first war
as a nation came not after September 11
2001 but in 1801 as a response to
jihadist raids on American ships for
booty and slaves after meeting with an
ambassador from barbery Jefferson sent a
letter to Congress saying we took the
liberty to make some inquiries
concerning the grounds of their barbar's
pretensions to make war upon Nations who
had done them no injury and we observed
that we considered All Mankind as our
friends who had done us no wrong nor had
given us any provocation
the Ambassador from barbar answered us
that it was founded on the laws of their
Prophet that it was written in their
Quran that all nations who should not
have acknowledged their Authority were
Sinners that it was their right and Duty
Muslims to make war upon them
non-muslims wherever they could be found
and to make slaves of all they could
take as prisoners check out Quran 95 the
sword verse and that every musl or
Muslim who should be slain in battle was
sure to go to paradise
assuming you need more examples here is
a minuscule sampling of what Europeans
thought of Islam throughout the
centuries according to theophanes an
important Eastern Roman chronicler who
was born around
758 he wrote quote he Muhammad taught
those who gave ear to him that the one
slaying the enemy or being slain by the
enemy entered into Paradise that's Quran
9111 and he said Paradise was carnal and
sensual or Jes of eating drinking and
women also there was a river of wine and
the women were of another sort and the
duration of sex greatly prolonged and
its pleasure long enduring and all sorts
of other
nonsense also according to Thomas
aquinus one of Christendom most
influential theologians and philosophers
born around
1225 he wrote he Muhammad seduced the
People by Promises of carnal pleasure
and he gave free reign to carnal
pleasure in all this as was expected he
was obeyed by carnal men as for the
proofs of the truth of his Doctrine
Muhammad said that he was sent in the
power of of his arms which are signs not
lacking even to robbers and tyrants in
other words Muhammad's proof that God
had sent him was that he was able to
conquer and plunder others which is not
exactly impressive Thomas is saying he
continues Muhammad forced others to
become his followers by the violence of
his arms although a contemporary of
Thomas aquinus Marco Polo born around
1254 was far from a bookish scholar
being a merchant and World traveler yet
he made very similar
observations Marco Polo
wrote according to their Doctrine
whatever is stolen or plundered from
others of a different faith is properly
taken and the theft is no crime while
those who suffer death or injury by the
hands of Christians are considered as
Martyrs if therefore they were not
prohibited and restrained by the powers
who now govern them he's referring to
the Mongols they would commit many
outrages these principles are common to
all
sarasin when the Mongol KH later
discovered the depraved criminality of
one of his Governors Ahmed poo writes
that the K's quote attention went to the
doctrines of the sect of the sarasin
meaning Islam which excuse every crime
yay even murder itself when committed on
such as are not of their religion and
seeing that this Doctrine had led the
accursed Ahmed and his sons to act as
they did without any sense of guilt the
Khan was led to entertain the greatest
disgust and Abomination for it for the
sect of the sarasin meaning Islam so he
summoned the sarasin and prohibited
their doing many things which their
religion allowed let's fast forward
here's what John Quincy Adams America's
sixth president who was born before the
Revolutionary War in
1767 had to say about
Islam quote adopting from the new
revelation of Jesus the Faith and Hope
of immortal life and of future
retribution he Muhammad humbled it
meaning piety and religious living to
the Dust by adapting all the rewards and
sanctions of his religion to the
gratification of the sexual passion he
poisoned the sources of human Felicity
at the fountain by degrading the
condition of the female sex and the
allowance of polygamy and he declared
undistinguishable against all the rest
of mankind the essence of his Doctrine
was violence and lust to exalt the
brutal over the spiritual part of human
nature according to Alexis de tovil I
think that's how it's pronounced born in
1805 a French political thinker and
philosopher best known for his popular
work Democracy in America he wrote I
studied the Quran a great deal I came
away from that study with a conviction
that by and large there have been few
religions in the world as deadly to men
as that of muhammads as far as I can see
it is the principal cause of the
decadence so visible today in the Muslim
world and though less absurd than the
polytheism of old its social and
political Tendencies are in my opinion
more to be feared and I therefore regard
it as a form of decadence rather than a
form of progress in relation to paganism
itself then there was Theodore Teddy
Roosevelt born around 1858 and he's the
26th president of the United States and
an accomplished student of history
according to him quote Christianity was
saved in Europe only because the peoples
of Europe fought if the peoples of
Europe in the 7eventh and 8th centuries
and on up to and including the 17th
century had not possessed a military
equality with and gradually a growing
superiority over muhammadans who invaded
Europe Europe would at this moment be
muhammadan and the Christian religion
would be exterminated wherever the
muhammadans have had complete sway
wherever the Christians have been unable
to resist them by the sword Christianity
has ultimately
disappeared I can go on and on with many
more examples see my book sword and
Scimitar where I have many more quotes
from the contemporaries who dealt with
Islam over the centuries but the point
should be clear even so some at this
point May argue that these and other
historic charges against Islam are mere
byproducts of Christian Western
xenophobia and intolerance for the other
but if that were true how does one
explain that many of Islam's Western
critics also praised other non-western
civilizations as well as what is today
called moderate Muslims for example
aside from speaking well of the Pagan
Mongols Marco Polo also held the brahans
of India the Hindu religious leaders as
being quote most honorable possessing a
hatred for cheating or of taking the
goods of other persons and despite Marco
Polo's criticisms of the sect of the
Saras he referred to one Muslim leader
as governing with Justice and another
Who quote showed himself to be a very
good Lord and made himself beloved by
everybody unquote perhaps British
Statesman Winston Churchill born around
1874 who once went so far as to compare
Pi Muslims to Rabbit dogs in his book
The River War check it out best summed
up the matter he
wrote quote individual Muslims may show
Splendid qualities but the influence of
the religion paralyzes the Social
Development of those who follow it no
stronger retrograde Force exists in the
world in short islamophobia literally
fear of Islam has been the mainstream
position among non-muslims for nearly
1,400 years ever since Muhammad started
attacking killing and enslaving
non-muslims infidels in the name of his
God and it is because his followers
continue hating attacking and killing
infidels that islamophobia exists to
this day therefore that which Muslims
routinely experience to quote from
Biden's anti-islamophobia document has
never been due to baseless stereotypes
but rather reality and self-preservation
on the part of the Infidel people have
eyes and ears to see and hear with and
they act accordingly